there have been more funny moments in
like
death row execution chambers over the
last 20 years
than in snl skits
[Laughter]
for our next edition of try to laugh we
are going to try
to harpoon the great white whale this is
the moby dick
of unfunny woke garbage we've tried and
failed to laugh
at jokes told by feminist comedians
many times but this is a little bit
different this i think is a greater
challenge
this time we're going to try to laugh at
saturday night live
the the modern current version of it
what i have to say right now might be a
little cringe
now as you know snl has not been funny
for about 20 years
and that's probably being generous
samantha b has told more funny jokes in
the last two decades
than snl has yeah they're landing on my
face now that might be going a little
too far
put it this way there have been more
funny moments
in like death row execution chambers
over the last 20 years
than in snl skits first time
i have no idea how it manages to stay on
the air except that it comes on at night
and everyone's either asleep or drunk
when it comes on late on a saturday
night
so i think maybe no one's like noticed
how bad it's gotten
it's allowed to just linger on lifeless
half dead dried up shriveled confused
there's an obvious joe biden joke here
but i'm trying to think of another
analogy
true international depression i can't so
yeah i like joe biden we're gonna look
at the most recent season
and which is now mercifully over and
we'll check some of the skits to see if
we can find something any
anything worthy of even a modest chuckle
that's where i'm setting the bar
not even laugh it's like this is a try
to chuckle thing we'll start with this
skit titled no more masks and now
a message from dr anthony fauci
it's your boy fauci the patron saint of
purell
as you probably heard we got some very
good news this week and i'm not just
talking about jlo and ben affleck
the cdc announced that people who are
vaccinated no longer need to wear masks
outdoors or indoors pretty great right
this is kate
mckinnon right why is she the resident
impressionist over at snl
something should work but do they isn't
an impressionist supposed to you know
be good at impressions i always say life
is like a box of chocolates
do you have what it takes a guy
legislates from the bench but he
measures
from the balls isn't that what you want
out of an impressionist
yeah no i don't know hers are all
terrible kate mckinnon is about as witty
and funny as
like your drunk aunt at thanksgiving
that one didn't count
anyway the point is um she's not very
fun we're going to give this a chance
because there should be a lot of
potential here to make some funny
jokes and have a funny skit uh so we'll
keep we'll keep watching
a lot of people had questions such as
what does that mean
what the hell are you talking about is
this a trap
so to clear things up i found a few
doctors at the cdc who minored in
theater
and i asked them to reenact various
scenarios in order to demonstrate
correct
mask behavior and remember they only had
24 hours to put this little show
together so
please welcome the cdc players and their
first scene
man walks into a bar
welcome to a bar thank you do i still
have to wear a mask
indoors you actually do not great
well as long as you're vaccinated no i'm
not oh
then that's bad well i'm entering a bar
at 11 a.m
did you really think i was vacs cause
that's on you
you're right i deserve kovitz and scene
just pausing to see if i can hear actual
crickets this is like the comedic
stylings of camilla harris
[Laughter]
this seems like the white house just
gave them a psa to perform
as comedy it is one of the problems for
snl
is that comedy should be transgressive
and countercultural and
you know rebellious and kind of and kind
of
that's what it should be and yes
offensive i mean
comedy should be all of those things and
snl is not that snl is now a mouthpiece
for the elites for the government
but let's move on to another sketch and
here we go
if you watch the undoing you might have
noticed that one of the stars of the
show
nicole kidman sang the theme song
we did inspired by nicole stars of your
other favorite shows are now singing
their theme songs
on now that's what i call theme songs
sung by the stars of the show
so enjoy this original theme song that
was cut from the opening
of queen's gamut chess and drugs and
drugs and chess girl playing chess
then doing drugs
now when you see people playing chess
you'll know that there
are drugs
hey if you like stranger things you'll
love the new season 4
opening credits performed by sheriff jim
hop hopper welcome to the 80s i'm about
to blow your mind
in hawkins indiana scary aliens you'll
find
lots of good actors but they're actually
good there's something strange in your
neighborhood
this script was written in 15 minutes
before showtime right
it it had to be well do it live [ __ ] it
probably by the janitor or someone
they have a team of writers right a team
of writers
came up with this and they all said it
was good
and it it made its way through a
purposeful process
onto the air did hackers like
hack into the snl broadcast and pipe
this skid in
to embarrass the show i'm just trying to
figure it out because this is bad we'll
try something that seems okay
i have no idea what this is this is the
this is a skit called the uli show
don't know what it is wild card let's
try it you're watching icelandic public
television
pop culture pops celebrities
games candy it's the only show
and now let's meet host iceland's number
one
social media
[Music]
we have big shot today
so cool ashland's number one comedy duo
is here football and greta
[Music]
hello so you have a good weekend paul
yes i visited my elf shrine uli
i can't continue with that is that a is
this a recurring bit they do is
there some context i'm missing maybe
context like lsd
that's the context in which i need to be
viewing this particular skit
so it seems that the snl kind of
fluctuates between banal
politically correct tripe and then stuff
that's weird
but forgets that weird in and of itself
isn't funny you have to be funny
as well as weird uh you start to make
jokes within the weirdness
you know what i i want to be fair
i want to really give them a chance
because i see that we have a
they did a bit on gay pride so they have
a skit on gay pride we're
gay pride month as i'm sure you're aware
you couldn't not be aware that we're a
gay pride month
um because every time you leave your
house you're beat over the head with it
by two by fours
here's a chance for some topical and
really edgy humor
about gay pride does snl have the balls
so to speak
to make jokes about gay pride to
actually satirize
the concept uh there's a lot to satirize
certainly and uh we will not get my
hopes up but we'll see
hey all you cheese gays and maize it's
the month of almost june and you know
what that means
friday's around the corner but last year
pride didn't happen so now we're making
up for lost time
part is a celebration yeah that's what
it's about
last year we couldn't meet up but this
time it's allowed
with my queer friends and allies now
it's time to go out
we get to do it all again now we're out
on the floor but i don't see my crush
he's not texting me back
well i'll just brush it off i have a
mental breakdown make my friends take
care of me
and i think yeah
yeah yeah it's fine again
we've been waiting so long it's tried
again
for so much
okay so they made the bold choice to be
not funny
once again it's a bold strategy cotton
by the way i hope all the people in that
sketch are actually gay otherwise this
would be appropriation which is very
offensive
i'm guessing they're probably safe as
far as that goes out of all the funny
and controversial things they could have
done with a gay pride
skit this is what they do instead
i'm not even sure what the joke is
supposed to be
all my queer friends and allies
that's hilarious yeah that's not funny
it seems with every sketch they they
kind of studiously examine
all the potential places to take it all
of the possible directions
and then they choose the least funny one
every time it's kind of impressive
actually
succeed in being mostly inoffensive but
they fail at being a comedy show
which is what their job is i think or so
the germans would have us believe
the good news though is that uh you can
put it on while you fall asleep
and you don't have to worry about being
kept awake
by your own laughter and that my friends
is looking on the bright side